if you want to hear how a trap that
never came to fruition in a previous Saw
movie makes an appearance in spiral then
stick around to the end of this video
welcome to things you missed this is the
first time we've ever gotten a big
establishing shot of the city and it
looks like New York previous saw films
took place in a state called the
Fairweather state and the city name is
always just metropolitan we never hear
the actual city name
there are definitely parts that look
like New York in the past but it's hard
to say if that means that the whole
series takes place there or if this is
simply a case of New York playing the
part of the fictional city another
possibility is that this doesn't take
place in the same city as the other
eight films if the new jigsaw is someone
who was inspired by John Kramer we could
be anywhere in the country now the one
big piece of evidence for that is the
fact that the subway system seemed to be
a big part of the story here possibly
even one of the traps involves the
subway that reminds me of the trap we
see in Jill tucks a dream and saw seven
which involves a device on a rail system
and interestingly enough has a spiral
thing going on this obviously was never
a real trap but Jill who if you don't
remember was John Kramer's ex-wife had
to get the idea from somewhere maybe
this was an idea for a trap that John
never used and is being brought back by
this new killer movie is called spiral
which is obviously a reference to the
pattern that shows up many times
throughout the Saw films most notably on
Billy the puppets I wonder if we learned
more about the thematic meaning behind
it all of the images associated with
jigsaw were chosen for a reason and I'm
guessing this is no different just look
at the spiral staircase in the shot and
the spirals that cover the traps across
the trailer perhaps the reason for the
spiral symbol is that it represents the
religious aspect of jigsaws following
John's work has always been kind of cult
aligned
he wears a robe and passes his teachings
down to his disciples the spiral symbol
has a great contrast to the symbols of
popular religious icons like the cross
with its rigid perpendicular edges we
see a Christian Church appear in the
trailer the full title is spiral from
the book of saw maybe the book is
essentially a Bible meant to pass down
the teachings of John Kramer in fact at
the beginning of the trailer the
character detective banks seems to be in
parting jigsaws code unto his partner
whether it is intentionally or not
John's motto was cherish your life and
here's what banks has to say about his
partner's relationship with his wife and
son
Emma's Charlie laughs kind of a weird
thing to say and I'm not saying that
he's jigsaw mostly
cuz that would just be too obvious in
the shot where a light is shined on this
figure underground I noticed that the
suspect isn't actually moving and that
leads me to believe that it could be a
mannequin you may remember John's
original workshop was located in a
mannequin Factory also take a look at
the shadow based on the angle of the
light it should be a long shadow but
it's not meaning that this part must be
a mural which may or may not be part of
a trap you would love this franchise
Admiral later in the trailer you can see
what looks to be a SWAT guy cutting
something with the buzzsaw
I think it would be really cool if the
new villain named himself buzzsaw also
it looks like he's cutting away one of
those secret doors like we saw in the
gideon meat-packing plant and saw five
the trap we see just before the title
card hits looks to be a new take on an
old classic the good old reverse bear
trap only it looks like the technology
has been updated for 2020 this one looks
to be a hands-free version it does look
as if this movie is pretty removed from
the last two entries saw seven and
jigsaw here's something interesting to
note the 7 saw films all share a common
look the color schemes are similar and
they use the same aspect ratio spiral
seems to have a similar aspect ratio and
look to the 2017 sequel jigsaw but as
far as we know there are no jigsaw
characters in spiral all we know about
the killer is that he's going after cops
the targeted cops that could suggest
that it's Logan Nelson from jigsaw whose
goal was to get revenge on the corrupt
cop who was responsible for letting his
wife's killer go free but again it seems
too obvious it feels as if this movie is
setting up a new jigsaw successor and
maybe spiral is part of a new trilogy or
tetralogy where each movie introduces us
to a new successor and in the final
movie they end up battling it out or
teaming up to make the ultimate team of
villains that's just an idea though
whatever happens I'll be covering
everything saw here on the channel
starting in March I'm gonna be doing
things you missed episodes for all of
the Saw movies including spiral and
horror history episodes on your favorite
saw characters so let me know if you'd
like to see me cover in the comments and
also these shirts will be available in
the merch store soon so make sure you
don't miss out on any of that content by
subscribing to seize these worlds for
new Horrors every week ring that death
bell for notifications and I'll see you
in the next one assuming we both survive